an arm like nolan ryan's used to come
along maybe
once a generation but these days it
feels more like
once a game now it's like ho hum every
night of the week somebody's throwing a
hundred
tom verducci is the senior baseball
writer for sports illustrated
and an analyst for mlb network pitchers
are definitely throwing harder and more
of them are throwing what i call
elite velocity i'm talking about 95 and
above
so what explains that revolution in
pitching
well a generation ago if you threw the
ball hard people would say
oh he's blessed with a strong arm it was
a god-given ability to throw the ball
hard
we've since figured out the baseball
industry has figured out that velocity
is something you can actually
teach and they're teaching it at gyms
like this
bobby how are you doing nice to meet you
bobby stroup is the founder of apec in
fort worth texas
this is our training floor there's ten
thousand square feet one of a growing
number of facilities where pitchers who
already throw hard
learn to throw even harder one apec
client white sox starter michael kopeck
has been clocked at 105. he improved six
miles an hour in one off season
so he was already throwing mid to upper
90s yes absolutely
works out here for an off season and is
touching 105
right the mets jacob degrom is nearly
unhittable this year
after adding miles per hour to his
fastball and unheard of five years in a
row
so how exactly does this happen to find
out i volunteered to sample the apec
program myself
working with pitching coordinator ryan
sullins palm away
so it's more here there you go you're
going to press we'll put them through a
series of drills a bunch of measurements
like
broad jump just a little things here and
there and we can put it into my system
and i'll print a two-page report
and it will identify every muscular and
neurological weak link on the body
in the case of a 40 year old morning
show host there was of course
plenty of weakness to find the tingling
is normal right
but listen to the potential results if
we could fix everything on you today
and get you solid and ready to go your
projective velocity today would be 90
miles an hour
90 miles an hour look at that from there
the apec approach is basically a
two-step
process combining a custom strength and
conditioning program focused on
rotational power
with throwing sessions that involve a
lot more than just long tossing a
baseball
a lot of times when you build up the
backside shoulder
almost always they throw the ball harder
yes it can all be a little funny looking
i often felt more like the karate kid
than nolan ryan
but programs like this are truly
changing the game of baseball
the average major league fastball has
improved about 4 miles an hour in the
past 20 years
and the number of pitches at or above
100 miles an hour
has jumped from a couple hundred in a
season to nearly a couple thousand
all of which means the pitcher has
gained even more of an upper hand in
baseball's most
basic contest and it may only get worse
what is the limit do you have a sense of
what the hardest
a human body can throw i think that
there's potential
to throw 112 113 if biomechanics were
perfect and it's the perfect specimen
and
they leverage gravity off the mountain
112
maybe 1213 a mere
100 mile an hour fastball takes just 400
milliseconds or so to reach the hitter
that is quite literally the blink of an
eye you have a split second to
to pull the trigger michael mccree is a
former college baseball player and the
author of mind of a superior hitter
a book designed to give batters whatever
advantage they can get
if somebody's throwing 100 miles an hour
it's going to be hard to see
obviously people ask all the time when
you see pitching that fast do you guess
and yes you mean you have to guess when
you say guess you mean the hitter has to
decide ahead of time i'm looking for a
fastball here i'm gonna
i'm gonna expect fastball you'll have to
expect a certain pitch
in a certain area mccree says hitters
will eventually adjust the baseball's
new arms
but tom ferducci says the game itself
may ultimately be forced to find a
solution
is this a crisis for baseball long
term it's a problem because now i think
you're risking
losing a generation of fans every fan
especially a younger fan
wants action that's the way we're wired
now we want more action
in a shorter period of time baseball is
giving people the inverse of that
less action in a longer period of time
so that equation
needs to change that's why i say it's an
existential crisis if you do
nothing you're going to continue to
alienate people with a lack of action
yeah there's not enough peanuts and
cracker jacks yeah you
so what's fascinating about your report
is that you know i always thought that
for example
tiger woods there's only one tiger woods
the way he hits that ball
cannot be replicated no matter how many
times or hours you spend in the gym
here you could become a 100 mile an hour
fastball thrower well
maybe nine well although i i sent that
clip to a friend of mine who i played
college baseball with and he says i will
bet
everything i own now and will ever earn
that you could never throw
uh but yeah this is a revolution in
human performance uh it's a rotational
athlete revolution and it'll come to
golf
it'll probably go to basketball it's
gonna spread throughout sports
and it's gonna change the way we watch
and what we enjoy well i think what's
interesting about it is that you think
about
hitting the gym and working those
muscles but according to the story they
also look at
what's happening in your brain and the
mental game part of it yeah
totally uh how to deal with is a big
little league i was terrible